[Applause]
[Music]
Thanks
so I'm guessing you've heard the saying
that everything is connected at some
point in your life and although I don't
want to bait whether or not everything
is connected I have noticed that
connections can be found everywhere they
really are a part of us of the world
from connections between people between
cultures with a language and nature
itself some being little connections so
all others connect us across time and
yet others only exists through the
meaning we as humans give them and in
these days when more data is being
collected every day than we could ever
hope to explore the variety and
connections being gathered is opening up
the possibilities to visualize more of
these often complex networks so I've
been focused on data visualization for a
few years now and I'd like to take on
the bigger data sets those that have a
lot of diversity so I can show context
and other stories besides the main
insight and ever since starting
freelancing in 2017 expanding the range
of data sets that I get to work with I
started to notice that I a lot of my
projects can be seen as revealing
connections some being very obvious and
others are more subtle and some end up
as actual network visualizations while
others need a different visual form to
best display the insights and I'd like
to take you along on a design journey
through several of my favorite connected
projects to reveal the ugly truth that
goes into creating these vague and
elaborate often interactive visuals and
stories so starting out with
straightforward connections literal
lines that are being drawn and only
through those lines of the connections
exist constellations so being officially
an astronomer I am biased by all things
space and I often seem to use our
universe as inspiration for the design
in my visualizations and I also find
myself creating a visualization about
astronomy every now and then and for a
final project that I did in a year-long
collaboration
I couldn't help but turn back to
astronomy yet again so this
collaboration called data sketches which
I did together with Shirley woo
consisted of 12 projects and the last
one that I tackled had to be about myths
and legends which through a winding road
of ideas left me two myths found in the
night sky so sure I can pinpoint some of
my favorite constellations who can't
write but those are all from Western
culture and I was wondering like what
have other cultures across space and
time seen in the same sky are there
certain shapes that almost every culture
identifies with so I drew a very simple
sketch in my neck in my notebook but in
my mind that sketchy circle would
eventually become something that would
kind of be inspired by these amazing
historical sky maps
well I then you know and full of
enthusiasm to get started
I cross my fingers hoping that diverse
cultural consolation data would be
available online thankfully though I
quickly stumbled upon Stellarium which
is a great FLE free planetarium software
and even better it's open source so
after some digging I found that they
have constellation data available for
about 28 different cultures from West
Irian to Chinese Hawaiian Maori and even
ancient Egyptian and Mayan
so after some initial data prep it was
ready to create my sky maps and I first
looked up some examples using d3 which
is the tool that I use most often to
create my visuals and I like to not have
to start from scratch or I look up these
sort of starting points and the code for
these examples was actually pretty
straightforward not it was very short so
this was one of those very few cases
very few where I was totally sure that
written the right code from the first
save and reload but of course you know
real life happens and all of my stars
appeared in the line so looking a little
bit closer I saw it missed like this
very subtle data step fixing that did
make my stars appear across all the page
but you know I have my confidence
deflated I didn't know if that was
correct or just a happy coincidence so I
added two things that would provide
context first the background grid
which seemed to indicate that things
were going in the right way and then the
the Western consolation lines because I
know them myself and then I immediately
saw Orion my favorite constellation by
the way so okay so the stars are in the
right place and this is in essence a sky
map but a very boring one though so I
started adding all kinds of touches to
make it both based more on reality so
making sure the Stars have the right
color and glow and using making these
sort of background streaks that mimic
the Milky Way but also remembering what
I liked about those historic sky maps
such as the embellishments of zodiac
signs and in clip decline and clipping
it all to a circle I I will just skip
over all of that and just final result
because it basically came down to
setting up my grid area although it was
a very long process but this is how the
sky may have looked after I was done
with all those touches and what would
make this sky map different from your
more conventional one was the inclusion
of many constellations at once to reveal
how different cultures had seen their
myths and legends in the same scattering
of stars and my way to reveal these
connections was pretty straightforward I
would focus on one star and then I would
show all the constellations that use
that one star star so I started out by
drawing these sort of small donut charts
around all of the stars that were being
used in these constellations combined
because often other stars besides the
one that I was focusing on were used in
multiple constellations and then I
wanted to draw parallel running lines
between these stars one for each of
these constellations and I always first
kind of want to draw it out in my little
notebook see how I can calculate it I
often defaulted trigonometry but in this
case it was actually solved by some
simple vector math instead a normal
vector for the people that you know like
Victor meant there are always some bugs
in there that you need to iron out if
you actually code it but that's how the
parallel lines actually came about quite
fast and this is how the how it looks
for all the constellations that use the
star Betelgeuse and when I first saw
this I said
I was so amazing to see how many
cultures had used that same sort of
rectangle tightened by a belt shape
however every cultures see something
different in that I mean from from
objects to animals mythical animals to
people and heroes but also interesting
to see how some just find their own
thing in the same shape like this sort
of man-like shape from the from the
Egyptians or this old man from the 2p
but the brightest star in the night sky
for example Sirius doesn't have a
consistent shape at all it's not even
used that often so brightness isn't
saying everything I also came across
this really cute looking deer in the
southern hemisphere which I hope to find
if I ever come you know below the
equator and what seems to be the most
common shape that most cultures
recognize apart from out of this
twenty-eight cultures is the one that I
guess everybody of us knows as the Big
Dipper it's used very very often and
this has basically turned it into a full
article going into even more of these
constellations and telling what I'd
found about the Stars and what an
constellations are used to really kind
of reveal how different cultures have
seen connections in yeah the same sky I
think when most people think about
connections they think about family ties
you know how you are connected to your
parents your grandparents and maybe even
further and for another project in that
data sketches collaboration the topic
was presidents and royalty and I've
always been intrigued by how inter
marriage the royal families really are
you know are they all cousins twice
removed or is it is it further than that
and it wasn't interested in only the
last few generations of one royal house
so I could create something more
extended looking like this no I wanted
as many connections as possible crossing
royal houses and going back hundreds of
years thankfully there was his giant
genealogy data said three thousand
people connected to European royal
families that I found on this
amazing-looking website it was from 1992
so I did have to spend a few more hours
on Wikipedia adding one or two more
generations in the main line of
succession looking up some other famous
royal
meantime but the problem that I have
with these sort of very heavily
interlinked networks is that it's very
hard to draw out anything less abstract
that just circles connected by lines and
that's because the best way to visualize
a network is almost always very inherent
to the actual connections themselves so
what I need to do is I need to put my
data on the screen as fast as possible
and then continue to design with code
which I did in this case so just my data
on the screen most basic settings that I
had and then this happened an explosion
of points and lines moving out of my
screen so I thought well okay I'll bring
everything a little bit back together
like increase the gravity but then I was
immediately left with a useless hairball
coloring it by year of birth didn't help
a bit but thankfully though in the
browser I can play with the laws of
gravity a little bit so I pulled his web
of heart by year of birth which was
better but it was still a rather on
insightful bundle and at this point I
already invested several hours into
playing with the network settings trying
different kinds of connections and
adjusting my data I was really ready to
just give up and try a different angle
you know like how much of the Royals
spending these days but I gave it one
last shot and that's when I decided to
focus on the current royal leaders so I
place these in a line and then I let the
vertical gravity depend on which of
these Royals these royal leaders you
were most closely related to and that's
when I finally saw it in sites for
example that the Queen of England and
Denmark and King of Norway are very
heavily interconnected but at the Prince
of Monaco lines separated from Europe
more than two hundred years ago and only
once I had a more and sort of a feeling
for the visual form of this
visualization did I look into the visual
design aspect and again being an
astronomer I'm biased by strana me and
the networks offer remind me of
constellations and that's really the
only reason why I turned it into a
starry night turning each person into a
little star so here is the final result
rotated 90 degrees and because I wanted
people to
experience sort of the how heavily
interconnected everybody was I added two
types of interactions so first we can
hover over any person and see how far
six degrees of separation reaches into
this web so for this lady Pauline of
wuertenberg she's connected to six
current leaders within just six steps
which I thought was pretty cool but also
maybe you're interested in something
somebody very specific like the Queen of
England here and let's see if I can find
our [ __ ] and then we can see the
shortest path between these two so these
two are actually not very closely
related
however the Queen of England and the
king of Norway are basically family so
yeah what I found out through this
project is that yes the entirety of
European royal families are connected
but maybe not as closely as a anymore as
I thought perhaps 200 years ago it was
that everybody was each other second
cousin twice removed though so I was
connected to the Guardian us by a mutual
friend and through the Gates Foundation
they have an entire new section on their
website that focuses on homelessness in
America and for their flagship piece
about how homeless people were being
bussed around the country they were
looking for outside help they had been
requesting data from cities and shelters
about the bus tickets that they handed
out to homeless people for a year and
they were looking for someone to bring
the insights to life through
visualizations and because I knew the
scope of this was too big for me alone I
asked surely from the data sketches
collaboration to become my partner on
this project so with my data science
background
I took the data cleaning and analysis
part on me and so each of these shelters
and cities had sent over a PDF files and
Excel files of all of the bus tickets
given out and of course every one was
completely different different formats
different columns but the truly bad part
came in the shape of typos and state
errors because to properly know where
each of the homeless people was was
going to I needed an existing City for
each destination so I wrote a collection
of fuzzy text matching techniques
I can figure out the actual city in
cases when an exact match wasn't found
I checked each of these automated
Corrections manually to see if I agreed
with them but I also had to spend hours
on google trying to find the actual city
in cases where even the fuzzy matching
wasn't able to make sense of it and
that's how I've come to the conclusion
that the US should never have created
four states that start with the letters
mi so many so many manual changes so
anyway after all of that data cleaning
was done resulting in almost thirty five
thousand journeys the analysis part
began so what did all of these trips
tell us I created tons of simple plots
dissecting the data in different ways
you know looking for trends what about
age and gender what about big versus
small cities what destination was most
popular but what if you try to account
for distance and just visualizing all of
these journeys would become an important
part but just plotting all of the
journeys on a map is creating a big mess
so I knew that needed a different visual
form so partly due to lucky timing
everybody involved could be in the same
room together for two days during which
we figured out the main story that we
wanted to tell and the different visual
designs to use for the separate
conclusions that we had to convey and
Shirley and me divided up the visuals
and my main one would be that map of the
US and already during this these
meetings did I draw out a rough design
where instead of showing all of these
lines at once each journey would become
its own little streamlet moving from
start to finish and then over time these
circles would start to grow behind the
cities to reveal how many of the
homeless people had actually moved there
so back home I had to programming all
and I try and start as basic as possible
just simple map the u.s. everybody was a
circle everybody starts and ends at the
same time and then somehow I was still
surprised to see like ten minutes going
into a big one but giving everybody the
same speed didn't made it only slightly
less weird this sort of shockwave across
the US but thankfully just making sure
that everybody sort of starts along an
actual time scale made it a lot
more real real and then I started trying
to add all kinds of different things to
sort of make it more elaborate than just
you know the streamlets moving from
start to finish it says being able to
follow a specific person for a little
while but eventually we really turned it
back down and focused only on these
animations and they're growing circles
because that was sort of the the main
concept so let me quickly show you the
final result so here's the article and
here we come on the map and this map
actually uses a technique that's called
scroll e telling where the map stays in
place and as the text goes along it the
map updates so that the text that you
read in the map the visualization shows
that these two are in sync and we're
coming up to the animation here so the
the goal of this animation is really to
convey this essence of all of these
journeys happening and that these people
are going to places all across the US
and there are lots of more
visualizations in this entire article as
well as videos and photos and interviews
to try and find a good balance between
telling the personal stories but also
revealing the high-level insights that
this very rich dataset gave us in case
you would like to read it you can just
google for a bust-out so now I look at
connections from the angle of the many
different cultures that we have on earth
so since 2003 UNESCO has been gathering
and safeguarding an ever growing list of
intangible cultural heritage which can
be anything from practices knowledge and
skills that people see as being part of
their cultural heritage and for the past
few years about 40 to 50 new elements
get added each year and the full list is
about 500 550 by now and you can browse
this list in this not so very inviting
table on the UNESCO website and if you
click on one of the cultural elements
you get more information as well as
videos and photos but there's something
else here too in the lower left called
concepts so experts of these cultural
elements have extensively tagged each of
them and what will become important and
you probably can't read but
primary and secondary concepts so if you
start comparing all of these tags these
concepts across the different cultural
elements it's probably no surprise that
some of these tags appear for more than
one of them such as vocal music being
part of all of these except for one well
one man within UNESCO had the sort of
vision where people would truly be able
to see and interact with these
connections to get a feeling for which
cultural elements were very similar
based on their shared concepts and to
invite further exploration so thankfully
he had convinced management to get him
some budget and he hired someone for the
backend and reached out to me for the
visual side so he was very upfront in
his first email about the scope of this
network so at the time there were about
415 cultural elements some regions
countries world heritage sites NGOs and
about a thousand different concepts
which combined together to create 2,000
nodes which is sort of more the
technical term for these entities in a
network and these 2,000 nodes between
them shared a whopping 12,000
connections and I totally wasn't sure
that I would ever be able to untangle
that mess I mean the Royal consolations
project from before had only four and a
half thousand connections and that was
already such a difficulty to tame but I
did not want to say no to UNESCO I saw I
just crossed my fingers hoping that it
would all work out some way so as with
the Royal royalty project I completely
skipped a sketching phase that would be
totally useless here I needed to plot
all my data on the screen and then see
where that would lens went and as
expected I ended up with hairballs giant
infectious-disease like looking things
kept appearing on my screen no matter
what I tried but there was one aspect of
the data that saved me not all of these
connections were of equal importance so
going back to those concepts so the
tango has primary concepts of dance
instrumental and vocal music but it has
a lot more secondary ones such as
emotions in choreography and although
UNESCO did not want to aggregate any of
these connections away they were okay
with me just
using these primary connections to place
the cultural elements in the
visualization so I temporarily filtered
out anything that wasn't a primary
connection to the culture elements and
then the result was this which to me was
a lot more ordens than all of the mess
that I'd gotten before so these yellow
ones are the cultural elements and the
concepts are all these teeny teeny tiny
circles and actually I thought that I
was starting to see communities which
would be a great way to entangle this
web one step further so in a network
analysis you talk about communities when
groups of these circles these nodes are
more heavily interlinked with each other
than they are with the rest of the the
network and smart people have written
algorithms to find these networks these
communities and then I can color them by
the different communities which I did
here and the bigger group still seem to
have the same color purple but they're
about four different purples there but
yeah I was definitely seeing the
potential and now I thought well these
these concept notes I actually want the
the most used ones to really stand out
so the more connections that one of
these concept notes would have like over
there and the center the bigger it would
become which is what happened here but I
wanted to help this one step further
because in a normal sort of network
simulation these circles all start in a
random place and then they kind of have
the network algorithm does its thing but
I thought well I know what community
state belong to so I'll just let them
start from all at the same space just in
a circle and then I will let the network
algorithm do its thing and pull these
things around and when I saw then that
most of these circles stay very close to
their initial location only a few of
them are kind of drawn towards other
places that for this particular network
looking at it from the angle off
communities is is quite fitting so then
that you reintroduce at introduce
everything that I'd filtered out first
placing them like on an average location
running a second network algorithm that
kind of shovels it back around going to
a different color palette by now as well
and yeah so this was the basic setup of
these circles and I quite liked how if
you if you doomed in really
how it reminded me of looking at these
images of outer space and my client at
UNESCO without me saying anything
started calling this visualization the
constellation and of course I don't
object against any kind of astronomy
related names so with the circles
figured out was trying to look at these
lines you know but you gray and straight
lines is boring so I made them colored
and curved but yet twelve thousand lines
at full opacity is one big mess so again
I had to iterate and came up with this
approach where if you hover over any of
the entities you see all of its
connections with the primary ones thick
and secondary ones thin and then if you
don't hover over anything it actually
only really reveals the primary
connections but it doesn't really end
there though because the client also
wanted it that if you were to hover over
a region it will go down to all the
countries which will go down to all of
the cultural elements and you'd have to
be able to send a query to the
visualization which would then all fix
themselves and multiple cultural
elements if you just fixed one of the
cultural elements by clicking on it you
would still have to be able to hover
over and get information about
everything else in the visualization if
you doomed in far enough all of these
circles would need to be start showing
the images off the cultural elements
you'd have to be zoom and pan around in
the first place and of course I have to
be some sort of mobile modal that gave
you more information about whatever it
was that you wanted to know more about
and that's really just the tip of the
iceberg but just to show that there's
more going on than just the visual
design this is the actual thing so we
can sort of zoom in and just pick one I
am no got to theater I don't know how to
pronounce that I'm sorry we can click
this and then see what the connections
are so for example it's representative
literally works comes from Japan so you
can go there and see where Japan has all
of its connections so there's also washi
over here which again is connected to
paper craft works and technical skills
fibers but we can also go and see that
it's connected to apprenticeship which
is part of a different kind of community
which again is connected to and that's
kind of how it wants to invite you to
explore
this vast network of connections between
cultural elements that was interesting
yeah thankfully UNESCO was happy with
the result even so much that they
postponed the initial online launch
until the actual yearly convention when
new items are being added to the list
which was really really cool and they
even got me some extra budget to make
more visualizations about other things
like domains and threats and looking at
it from her like a natural nature side
so yeah it was really a fun project and
we can also find connections in the way
that in language depending on how you
look at sentences and similarities
between sentences so for the past few
years
Google News lab has been asking data
visualizers to create date of his driven
stories based on google data and I've
had the fortune to create one of them
already so he was really happy when they
reached out to ask me to do another one
and I came up with some ideas and
discussed him with my contact at Google
but there was one that really stood out
to both of us doing something about pets
so having this cute little fluff ball in
my house for at least 15 years
I often all not often anymore but you
know I find myself on Google every now
and then trying to figure out why she's
showing some weird behavior like why the
need to climb in to anything box like
the table was uninteresting before put a
box on it it's her new favorite spot and
I was wondering like how how do people
in general use Google to better
understand their pets and this was sort
of the the idea I would get the most
popular questions that follow the words
why does it cat why do cats why does my
cat or and the same for dogs and a few
more of these variations and then
investigate that further it says kind of
look for trends and interesting insights
and weird outliers and I drew a really
simple sketch this is basically my
sketches this is also what I send the
client with some extra and you know
explanations but my my main
visualization would be that sentence
tree in the top left where I would
basically break apart all of the
sentences and recombine them where they
have similarities but
let me let me explain that a little
better so eventually I got about 2,000
of the most popular questions that ask
why about cats but if I downsize that I
can say give me everything that has two
word like as the first word so why do
cats like but even within that there are
actually three sentences that have the
word boxes as the second word so I can
combine those one step further and if I
do the same for all of the other
sentences I turn it into a treat and I
can build up a sentence by following it
from left to right so why do cats like
to and then this goes to a lot go in the
bathroom with you why do guys like to go
in the bathroom with you that's true
Cecily that's never mind do you might so
this is seeking out a lot of space so I
wanted to downsize all of these lines
and put them in like a circular
arrangement around that initial word and
scale the circles based on how popular
those specific questions were but this
is just one aspect of data and I wanted
to visualize all 2,000 sentences at once
so again I started off with a simple
Network and then thought I would just
kind of adjust things until the
connections become apparent but yeah I
also really had to increase the size of
these circles because I wanted to put as
many of the actual words inside the
circles but that took up so much space
that you couldn't really see the
connections anymore they were just kind
of gray blurs going outward I wasn't
totally not clear like who's the parent
of this circle over here and that's when
I started trying all kinds of different
things to try it to see if I could make
that a parent like grouping all of the
children of the same parent but then it
was still unclear who that parent was
and at the strangest times I would get
like weird things happening such as here
I still do not know why these circles
start rotating faster and faster I
really I just you know controls it until
it stopped happening and then try it
again and then like two hours later I
would do this again I literally still
haven't figured out
I thought well maybe if I group all of
these children off the same parent
sentence into one larger circle so I
only have one line running between the
start and the end and when I have more
radical ideas I I first draw them out to
see if they kind of seem to make sense
here I had it working but again looking
at it I was like yeah this is not really
an improvement it's not still not
inviting people I think to explore and
one to see what's inside chaos and
whatever I tried with these sort of
packed circles or whatever I wanted to
do it just wasn't working it still felt
like it was intimidating and not
inviting but I tried so many different
things and so many different ideas and
even at the end I I made it so that each
of these circles was draggable so I
could actually move them with my mouse
to exactly their way that I wanted it to
look and took me about two hours to get
that right side sort of handled and then
I took a step back and I was like yeah
no no it's not working it's not working
so you know 40 hours after having
started with that first simple network
did I throw in the towel and give up
finally but I still needed to visualize
the data somehow I mean it was getting
paid to do it so I look back at one of
the many tests that I did during those
40 hours where for one night actually
cut the connection to that sort of
central cat circle so that each branch
would be its own mini tree like we saw
like before but we also have like a need
and meow and half of course that took
some time to get working but I remember
thinking that these mini trees actually
looked quite interesting and now in
retrospect perhaps even better than the
best result that I've gotten from that
full sentence tree so I wanted to
continue with these mini trees again
drawing out some ideas in my notebook
and eventually went with one that would
sort of enclose each minute we into its
own circle so this is basically what
happens I have a bunch of circles I
place them randomly on the page then I
let an algorithm figure out how to place
them with which reduces as much overlap
as possible then within each of these
bigger circles I run
org algorithm that creates each mini
tree but this all happens under the hood
doesn't actually need to be animated I
just I'm just interested in the final
result and when I saw this and I was
probably biased after 40 hours of
failure I was finally happy I thought
that I'd found a good compromise in
between giving people access to this
full data set of 2,000 questions while
not being too overwhelming and
especially with if you can do that it's
sort of the final layer of looking into
the design which I made very colorful
and sketchy and whimsical to really try
and invite that kind of playfulness of
wanting to you know hover your mouse
over this thing and see what it actually
happens you know why do cats groom each
other and then fight and it's very
specific i groomed themselves why do
they have stinky poop like which animal
does a head does not have stinky poo but
yeah there are lots of you know fun
things in here that I hope will sort of
make people wanna when I explore but of
course that wasn't the only
visualization on this page so the entire
process started again with the other
visuals I went through I don't know how
many color palettes and font choices I
had to write the text for the analyses
in the page and come up with a layout
for the page there had to be different
kinds of interactions on desktop and
mobile really exploding the underlying
complexity
especially when the need for this sort
of search box became apparent and the
mini tree visualization you know from a
personal perspective I really hate that
we have smartphones you know personally
I'm very happy but professionally it
really it really makes my life very
difficult but here is the end result so
here we can we start you know with
generals we quickly and choose between
cats and dogs on the go with cats I
didn't make these animations by the way
they're done by Juliana Chen really
great animator we go into like a very we
start easy just not all the day that
once but just something fun like you
know the cats versus cucumber so a lot
of people ask why do cath you know why
are they afraid of cucumbers in
different kinds of ways you know why are
they afraid or hate me that's so sad but
in your head
so there are sounds and licking and
biting and only once I've sort of
introduced you to this data set do I go
into like and here's everything have fun
but we can also look at this data from a
very high-level point if you like what
are the most popular questions and does
that change between my cat versus a
general cat and it does very
interestingly and of course cats versus
dogs and then there's you can do the
same for dogs but yeah so this was the
most time-consuming project I have ever
worked on but it was also a lot of fun
because the the topic was so dear to me
okay so I want to end with a project
that actually looks doesn't look at
humans anymore connections between
humans but looks at systems instead so I
was approached by Alice which is a
startup from South Africa and they are
using machine learning to try and find
good investment opportunities and to do
this they've created their own operating
system Alice OS on which the business
runs and they wanted me to visualize the
system so the data each data point that
I got was a service some tasks that is
being run which can be something as
simple as copying a file to something
that is running a predictive model and
each of these services belongs to a
certain domain of similar services like
all file handling services or all
machine learning services and what makes
the connections the hierarchy is the
fact that all of these services can
create other services which can create
other services and so on and they asked
me to create a visualization that could
be used for both management purposes so
give an overall view of the system to
clearly show task dependencies also
clearly show the different domains and
some metadata but it also had to be used
for marketing ends so it had to be like
visually intriguing and and and I really
had to be in line with their brand which
was very black white and red and if you
if you know anything about data
visualization and you know colors is an
important thing to use to differentiate
data and I now I had black white and red
as that was an interesting challenge and
the reason why they came to me
that they felt that the Royal
consolations project would be a great
fit for their data so in the royalty
project we have time on the vertical
scale date of birth and then we use the
horizontal to separate this network into
the different current laurea leaders and
they thought well we can use time as the
creation time of the services and then
we will use domains as the horizontal to
separate out the network because
services in one domain can create
services in another and the way they
explained it it did seem to make a sense
it could be a possible option so I
started creating it but once I had like
a rough version working on my screen I
was looking at this so clearly it was
not working for Alice's data for one
these domain crossings happen but they
were very infrequent but the bigger
issue was that often and in retrospect
this seems to make sense a lot of these
services are created within minutes if
not seconds from each other and after
which nothing would happen for a
relatively long period of time
so all of these things wanted to be at
exactly the same point along that time
axis creating these circular blobs I
went on for a little while longer and
doomed to fail just putting it all into
one line and then making it in through
spiral so it would be really long time
axes but it totally wasn't showing
anything useful
no no dependencies or whatnot so I
emailed my client and I told them that I
really needed to take a step back and go
into a proper design phase and see what
would actually work so for the next
three days I would draw out a simple
sketch and then I would spend a few
hours making it into a reality with
Alice's Dana so starting out with
something as simple as a circle where
everything was grouped by domain and
then sorted by creation time and like
well what about like different spokes
where each spoke was a different domain
but yeah you'd think you could get into
trouble where one domain was very very
active and then maybe it wouldn't fit
the screen anymore
what about networks then but yeah then I
saw seven little hair balls and I was
not ready to face that may be a radial
tree which was indeed very good it's
showing the hierarchical dependencies
however this could
work because of the domains again a
service from one domain could create a
service in another and you could not
separate this out clearly by domain
going back to this folks then and make
it an inter spiral to conserve space but
now these lines are kind of crossing
over other data points especially for
these sort of outlier services that
would create a bunch more so abandoning
that again trying circle packing as a
weird outlier idea but yeah nothing was
obviously working so after having run
these tests I kind of took a step back
and thought about you know what do I
like from the things that I'd seen like
what small things and part of that was
that initial circle where the domains
were clearly separated and they were
sorted by time and that radial tree
where the dependencies were clearly
visible going outward so I thought well
maybe I can combine those two things and
I called it a depth circle where these
services are still in a circle but now
it's shield the child service is moved
one step further outward than its parent
may be a little bit difficult to see but
these two circles show exactly the same
data and each service is that exactly
the same angle around the circle however
in the right one they are moved one step
further outward than their parent
service so I shared this idea as a depth
circle with my client and thankfully
they were happy
so I said about making it more on brand
and also happy that I did not need
really any more colors than just three
of them being inspired by these sort of
long exposure photos that they also use
for their branding if the car taillights
I made they're currently running and
failed services like glow up to make
them stand out more but I also want to
sort of tackle these lines connecting
the two by making them look more
streaked again like these serve car
lights by drawing several lines on top
of each other and each one slightly
jiggled figuring out a formula that
would jiggle the right amount for both
short and long lines took a little bit
of a bit of experimenting this kind of
how the end result of that looked and
now you can see a little bit like here
where one a service in one domain can
create a service in another and then I
said about making it animated
interactive and being able to handle
data updates but that's not really the
fun stuff so here's the final result
where you can hover over a certain
domain or you can see within that domain
how a specific hierarchy of services
went or for this one you can see that
this service actually failed because two
levels down this particular service
failed somehow we can also click on any
of these domains to give it more space
to see if you really want to focus on a
specific domain they can also go to a
different time frame because it has to
constantly update like every I don't
know how often they do it we're like
every hour it's sort of season update
and it uses the same animation to kind
of give an idea of like what is still
overlapping between the two time frames
yeah so I was eventually really happy
that I managed to visualize this complex
system of services especially looking
back at how dreadful that initial idea
looked like I said before like each each
network needs its own unique way of
visualizing the connections because it's
so inherent to the connections in the
network it doesn't just stop there there
are ways there are connections in the
way an organization is set up there are
different kinds of connections between
people besides family such as friends
and lovers connections across time such
as visualizing all of the fights the
characters as Dragonball Z have appeared
in and I hope that by showing you all
these different things that like that
you've seen how amazingly diverse
connections can be and I found that
revealing the intricacies within really
requires a very creative and iterative
and custom approach and yeah sometimes
connections can be simple and you can
actually draw out a design beforehand
but more often than not they are so
complex and elusive and unknown that
there's nothing else for me to do we
just plot all that data on the screen
from step one and then continue to
design with code so I can see how each
of my design choices affects the network
as a whole so if you want to see any of
these projects up-close and play with
them and see even more connected
projects you can find them in my
portfolio also database really
lives on Twitter so if you're guessing
everybody's there but come join me there
if not and finally thank you very much
for your attention
[Applause]
[Music]